That's right, it's a big problem that every boy around the age will hit.
Big brothers are much more experienced than us.
That's right. I'll try to solve anything
.
Imai-kun, there's nothing I can do when I'm
told that it's
okay.  Even though it's a temple, what's the story? Well, the
world in which we live is different.
[Music
] I don't think it can
help. Who is that person you fell in love with?
Tara isn't a group that blames him
. It's a youth. Wow, please give me that
kind of
thing.
It ’s super cool and the best date plan
.
It ’s a difficult disco and it ’s a mood-filled matic.
Can't you say such an embarrassing thing?
Well, where was the communicative power when I first met?
Appearance Titan and
tape
already taken s What is it?